my name is Dan Powell I am the director
of community platforms here in central
IT presenting with me today I have two
of my colleagues James Tudor Owen and
Mike vana Munoz and we're going to talk
to you a little bit about the
technologies that we offer that you can
use to engage with your community how
many of you were able to see Nate
Nickerson this morning and talking about
audience insights very cool so a lot of
the technologies that I'm going to be
talking about the data of which will
give you insight into what your
community experience actually is and
once you have that data then you can
turn around you can make better
decisions about you know the experience
that you want to somebody to have with
your department or your school or unit
and and and you know you can start to
create that experience for them based on
what they need this is a bit of a
forward-looking picture you will see the
the large Salesforce piece in the middle
that is you know mainly because that is
our chosen CRM here on campus how many
of you are our Salesforce users now do
we have we've got a okay there we go
so it's it's it's a really cool thing so
this isn't this represents where we're
trying to get to once we start to knit
together all of these different
technologies they feed into that that
Salesforce CRM and that CRM is is what's
going to be able to generate that 360
degree view of what some of these
experiences here on campus it's not
necessarily where we're at today where
we are at today is we have Salesforce as
a CRM layer in it it it consumes all of
the the data from RL of our upstream
systems of record and so everybody that
we communicate with and the Yale
community gets channeled into this the
CRM layer as well as anybody that is
interested in our content around the
globe gets channeled into the CRM layer
and then that layer feeds marketing
cloud or Yale message which is our
digital engagement platform which mike
is going to talk to Mike phenomenas is
going to talk to you about in just a
minute but there's also other periphery
technologies that we offer here at Yale
that we're just starting now to pull
into
and integrate with with Salesforce so
Cvent which is our conferencing Stephen
was a technology that organized today's
conference the digital of confidence and
Qualtrics as a survey tool also
integrates in with with with Salesforce
as do the other technologies that we're
going to talk to you about today so this
is our actual agenda for today so I'm
going to start off talking to you a
little bit about what we do on the
customer relationship management and I
recognize that we are an institution at
university we do not have customers
customer relationship management is the
industry's word for it but please feel
free to substitute that C for colleague
or constituent or community then I'm
going to hand off to Mike Vinny Munoz
and he's going to talk to you about
digital engagement using Yale message
and then James to Tyrone is going to
take us the rest of the way and talk to
us about calendar and events room
reservation systems and survey here on
campus so starting off with customer
relationship management this is really
the heart of the understanding of what
you were of what the community
communities experience is that you serve
you notice it on the other page as being
that Center focal point it tracks all
the interactions in conjunction with
your business process so it doesn't have
to be around people it can certainly
it's it's commonly around people but it
can also be between like assets like
equipment located in rooms or people
attending events it's very flexible and
it's flexible to meet your business
process you know you might be thinking
it's like okay but I track interactions
today anyway and you know so do I you've
got outlook people you know we hear a
lot about Excel Outlook hey you know I I
also group my emails in conversations so
I can see who's talking to when and what
that response part has been but when we
talk about CRM we we talk about taking
those conversations and then we put them
in context of what your business process
is so like if you have a study for
example and say you have a
that's working on this study you're
having this email conversation with
somebody is that at the beginning of
that process is in the middle of that
processes at the end of that process so
it can put those conversations into
context of what your business process is
and what you're trying to accomplish
the other thing with Outlook is those
are conversations that are just between
you and somebody and might exclude the
rest of your team that's working on it
with without look it integrates in with
Salesforce you can actually just assign
that assign those email conversations
directly into your CRM and so it
attracts it there and it gives a
disability to the rest of the team so we
all are on the same page walking through
the business process it's very cool very
powerful but it's about adding that
context and that visibility of where
someone or something is in their
engagement path we do hear a lot about
that Excel spreadsheet the different
groups to use to track their
interactions and this is just you know
instead of that being a very flat
spreadsheet that's hard to keep up with
this is a mini to many type of a
relationship that you know it's more
robust and allows you to actually track
and have visibility into your process
it's all about process it's it's it's
very flexible
we chose Salesforce many many years ago
both tactically and strategically if you
think about Yale as an institution we
support many different industries and
many different schools and units and we
all have different business processes so
we needed something that could be
flexible to adapt to each of those
different unique processes but by still
but still being centered around whatever
that's objectives that you're trying to
understand better whether it be a person
or an asset or something and Salesforce
gives us that which is which is why it's
on campus I'm gonna give you a few
different examples of of instances we
have on campus so this is a really fun
one with the psychology psychology
department where we're you know they're
using Salesforce in a way to understand
families and their children in the
studies that they are participating in
now and historically as well as showing
things like tracking
appointments and no-shows and shows
another example on campuses conferences
and events will call this like a CRM
plus with them what we did is we
configured it so that they can track
their the in to end process so from the
time somebody reaches out as a lead to
maybe host an event on campus walking
them all the way through the process to
the time that they're actually managing
that the logistics of that event on
campus in and and it also manages
support issues during the event I'm
using a case management module and and
this one is also another fun example of
a CRM on campus is for the Yale School
of Public Health if you can imagine
match.com where you have a lot of
students that need mentoring and an
alumni that might want to act as mentors
and so it takes alumni opting in to be a
mentor creating a profile for themselves
and then allowing the students to come
in and research the different alumni
that have opted in and and then they can
favorite them and then they can start
you know building their own relationship
with with their new with our new mentors
it's very fun very cool very powerful
stuff and once you have all these types
of things within your your process
documented and you're working through it
you can you start to have some really
rich analytics around that and once you
have those analytics it gives you even
more insight and more understanding
about what you what the possibilities
could be to help her to meet your
community's needs so you might be
thinking to herself right now say gosh I
didn't know all this stuff I would love
to reach out and understand more and see
what else we can do so what does it like
to engage with us so you know for us
it's you just you reach out and we go
through some vetting to make sure that
we're understanding which technology is
the right choice for the problems that
you're trying to have and so let's say
that it does happen to be Salesforce on
the CRM side what we would do is we'd
really get to engage with you and really
understand
what are you doing right now how you're
doing it and and how you want to do it
better what your goals are and so once
we start to document out that entire
process we all get on the same page with
that and then we configure the tool for
you and it's a whole lot easier to adopt
and we've seen a lot of success with
doing that approach so that's my time
and I'm gonna hand this over now to Mike
to talk to you about yell message good
afternoon to everyone who uses yell
message in majority of the room who
attended our session just before lunch
so some of this might be regurgitation
for those people for other people
welcome yell message is a is a
communications digital communications
platform built on Salesforce in our
current state we are focusing on two key
features we focus in on the email studio
and journey builder email studio is
precisely what that is it's sending
email communications to the community we
gather data from our data sources here
at Yale so we connected into the People
Hub workday hopper and those lists can
be updated as those systems of record
are updated the other portion that we
are currently dealing with is journey
builder journey build is a really cool
feature in that you build a journey for
your list of people who you're
communicating with so you would have the
list of people you would set up the
journey to go as expected send out a
message and depending on what each
individual does within that journey
we'll send them down a different type of
path we've got a really cool journey set
up right now with organizational
development Travis is doing a phenomenal
job so we appreciate the partnership
thank you
[Applause]
but something like Travis does is that
there's certain classes that are set up
and participants need to do required
reading before the class so the
individuals on the list will get the
email the through the journey if that
person if someone doesn't open the email
or if someone does not click on the link
within that email a different journey
will be started up so if I'm in a class
and my class starts next Monday the
journey started today I got my email I
just kept ignoring it
Travis has set up that within two days I
mean receiving it ping Michael again
pinging pinging him until he opens the
email or until he clicks on the link so
that I read the required reading if I
don't do either of those and I show up
for my class and I'm ready to rock and
roll the instructor knows that I haven't
done anything and could possibly say
goodbye Michael come back next time when
you've done the prescribed reading that
we need for you to do for the class in
the future we've got two other great
tools that we're gonna focus on mobile
studio which is mobile messaging which
can also be integrated with the journey
builder so Travis is super excited about
that we know today's day and age
everyone likes their cell phone so if
you don't read the reading or open the
email we can then create a journey that
starts sending text messages to your
phone if you've opted in for that and
then social studio we all know the power
of social media it's come in we're going
to get them just some stats on way a
yellow messages on the campus first of
its a kudos to the team today or June is
our one year anniversary since we
adopted Yale message and in that
timeframe we bought on over 200
departments trained over 750 people
throughout about 32 other departments
ready to come on board another great
success is up here we are with the Yale
brand we've got the Yale font and we are
fully accessible which we know is a huge
requisite another great statistic
year-to-date so
first five months of this year we have
successfully sent over 30,000 emails to
34 million recipients we've had an open
success rate of about 40 percent which
is roughly about 8% better than it was
with our previous tool the other great
feature with the ill message is
obviously the analytics as dan was
referring to pulling the data
understanding the data with the
analytics that we receive we're able to
identify who the targeted audience truly
is and how they've interacted with us so
if you send out an email to let's do my
other number 34 million people which is
pretty huge but only a million people
start interacting with you you've now
got your targeted audience you know who
they are and you target them
specifically we are also able to get
open rates click rates so you'll know
who's opening your emails we'll know
who's clicking on the emails there's a
report within the email of which clicks
receive the highest percentage of clicks
so what your audience is actually
reading within that email over here you
can see a delivery rate we strive for
that 99 to 100 percent delivery rate you
you find out why people are not
receiving the emails if it's a hard
bounce you can click on the hyperlink
and you can see if that email address
was incorrectly written or that email
address just doesn't exist soft bounce
if a person's mailbox is full yellow
message we'll continue to try send that
email to the person for 72 hours
hopefully getting through to them and
then obviously a block bounce
unfortunately not much we can do with
that in the real world it's someone's
gone out and specifically blocked you we
did work with Salesforce and we keep up
with Salesforce on white listing our
domain name right now domain is message
that yelled at edu it is at a higher
white list than yelled at edu we're able
to track it we're able to push it and we
work with different constituents to make
sure that emails get pushed through
and then some really cool features is
when you start to get into your email
engagement you can see percentages of
who's gonna click on emails who's gonna
open emails so you get a true sense of
how you're communicating communities
engaging with you and that's it up next
I'm gonna hand over to James all right
so I'll be taking over to talk to you
all about our calendaring and event
management tools also our room
reservation system and our surveys will
do we use on campus so to get started
we're gonna take a look at calendaring
and event management which we support
through beadwork Cvent and crowd compass
basically what we're trying to do here
is provide a common set of tools that
will help in understanding your target
audiences again target audiences
engagement as well as to facilitate some
policy adherence while meeting some of
our critical requirements are in this
field around campus so some of those
requirements are going to be a calendar
of publishing and cross listing
submission and approval also third-party
integration we're looking to do about in
session management as well as payment
processing and then a mobile attendee
experience which is really neat and of
course as we've mentioned a few times
already reporting on top of all of this
so I'm gonna break down the difference
between calendaring and event management
just a bit because we've sort of found
over the years that there is sometimes a
bit of a difference in what people sort
of define as calendaring and also Events
Management so looking at calendaring
here we have our yell calendar of events
this is also known as the beadwork
system it's at calendar yale.edu and
basically this is our unified event hub
for the University it's our it's a great
opportunity for us to really be a part
of the vision of a unified GL here on
campus and it's intended to be the one
place to go for all of the events that
are taking place on campus and in that
way it improves the experience for
people that are looking to attend events
on campus as well as the general Yale
community and also some departments
around campus such as public excuse me
public safety and facilities so it also
improves visible
of your events as calendar yelled edu is
calendar yale.edu and it's linked
directly from yell daddy to you so it
really pushes people to come right to
this calendar system and and really
market what is taking place here around
campus so with the calendar here what
the requirements that we're trying to
meet are going to be those calendar
publishing and cross listing as well as
the submission and approval and then of
course we have third-party integrations
which are really interesting both custom
such as our integration with the Yale
arts calendar and also out of the boxes
such as our integration with Yale sites
and just a moment so in here on the left
hand side we can see our landing page
for calendar the calendar that yelled
Eddy vu and one thing to note about this
is that the Office of Public Affairs and
communications is our functional owner
for the calendar here however the
individual groups who are posting events
retain administrative ownership of their
events and some of the other groups that
are using the calendar include the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences the
Macmillan Center programs the School of
Management we have less campus we have
approximately a hundred different groups
that are actually using the calendar
currently and so now moving into our
event management tools which we support
with Cvent here on campus and Steven is
an event management system that
automates and simplifies the entire
event planning process and it offers
tools that run the entire gamut from
vendor excuse me ah venue sourcing all
the way to real-time dashboards and
reporting at the end of your event so we
can see here it provides us with a
number of different opportunities and
our lens here some of the requirements
we can see that were meeting are going
to be a registration and payment
processing of course we also have
marketing which is great and fits right
in with some of our other tools and then
some of our add-ons which are really
neat is we have an on-site solution
which is even cause their white glove
service
where they send people down here to
actually man your event and they handle
the registration process where they will
print ID cards handle check-in get
everybody set up etc and something else
that they offer which is really cool is
live polling so during the presentation
such as this you can actually get
feedback from your audience and have an
interactive discussion about something
that you're actually talking about so as
Dan mentioned earlier everybody
here today had an experience with
Stephen when they registered for the
digital conference right and then a
number of other groups are on campus are
using it as well um so the office of
development and the Yale alumni
association are two large users as well
as the law school school of management
we also have athletics which is really
interesting and then just a couple of
the features that are inherent with
Stephen as we saw already with this lens
here so we have an online event
registration program which provides also
a branded website experience and then of
course provides us that secure payment
processing the tool also allows us to
manage our attendees as well as our
speakers and our exhibitors and our
sessions and then of course you know it
provides us with that robust reporting
mechanism that is really required across
all of our tools so that steps us into
our mobile attendee engagement or
experience application and this is crowd
compass which is a subsidiary of Steven
and basically it's a mobile application
that your users can use while they're
actually attending an event and
basically what's the event
excuse me what crowd compass states is
that there's two primary reasons that
people attend a conference or an event
and that's so that they can engage with
your content and so that they can engage
with other people and crowd compass is
really really powerful for doing that as
it allows us to engage with our peers
through social networking and it allows
us to get engaged with our content and
our speakers through attendee and
speaker tools that are available the
other thing that it provides is an
ability for us to have another
opportunity to engage our you our
attendees with our brand in general so
we can see some of the in our second
bullet here some of the items that that
are really useful within the system is
going to be the session scheduling we
have speaker profiling interactive maps
and push notifications a couple of
really interesting things that have been
coming about lately is we've been seeing
a lot of integration with augmented
reality and wayfinding so for instance
at a Facebook conference a few a few
years back they actually had one of
these nice little badges here where you
flipped it over looked at it with your
phone and you had a 3d floor plan
representation of the campus that the
Facebook conference was taking place at
another example we've seen is using your
phone to sort of look where you're going
and having a dotted line that's
wayfinding you too
wherever your location is so for
somebody that's really not familiar with
the campus or the location it's a great
way I mean hopefully we still watch you
know and check both ways before we turn
the street or I turn the across the
street rather but you know one really
really interesting thing that I find is
that we see this statistic that on
average attendees for a conference check
their phone 200 times a day so if we
consider that statistic we can see how
very easily crowd come to speak can
become such a powerful tool and of
course with crowd compass some of the
groups that are using this is
commencement one of our biggest you know
events that are taking place on campus
we also do the Yale Harvard weekend we
have the school of managed welcome
weekend we have some orientations so we
have a number of sort of high profile
and profile events that are being used
through this application and again the
great thing about this is it really gets
right to the heart of your of your
attendees and it gives them an
experience that's beyond just
registration and understanding what's
taking place so moving on now I'm going
to talk about our room and booking
management system so this is the room
reservation system some of you might
also know this as EMS which is event
management system as opposed to expense
or emergency management system there's
no confusion with that at all right
so basically OMS is our space and
booking management system it also allows
for some resource booking one of the
great things about this is it allows for
granular access and when appropriate we
can also do an automated user load
there's also an excuse me an integration
with exchange as well as with banner and
it's really powerful in its ability to
provide us with some some functionality
around scheduling scenarios and
optimization and we also have of course
API access and and let's see here and
then we of course as with all of our
other tools have a robust reporting
mechanism as well so we can see that
there's a number of different things
that EMS can do and I like to call it a
space and object management system
because it's not really just about rooms
anymore
in fact the School of Drama is using
this system to manage some of their
vehicles that they allow for check-in
and check-out and in addition to the
School of Drama we also have the law
school which is actually the group that
implements a TMS on campus about 10
years ago and
then the School of Public Health sort of
adopted it as well before it became
centrally managed and now we have about
2000 different groups including School
of Management who in all in all fairness
is managing their own instance of EMS
however they are using EMS and then we
also are recently rolling out the
medical library why CBA the art gallery
and a number of various departments
around campus so one of my one of the
most exciting things for me that are
coming about right now is digital room
signage so digital room signage is a
tablet size device that is installed
outside of a space and basically it
provides an application that shows you
whether or not the room is available and
what's taking place in that room over
the course of the day also if you choose
to do so you can have people interact
with this device as they're walking up
to a space so if the space is available
somebody can walk right up and reserve
the space or if you have a lot of
problems with people not actually
showing up for their reservations you
can actually require them to check-in so
that that way if they don't check in the
space is released and somebody else can
then use that space and you're not just
sitting there with with a wasted room so
this is an example of the application
and right now we have this also
implemented in a number of places around
campus the School of Management is is
one really great example and if you ever
have an opportunity to go over to their
site you can see this on most if not all
of their rooms within the building
divinity has also implemented a number
of these devices along with this
institute of sacred music nursing is
going to be putting in about 80 or so as
a part of their renovation process and
the center excuse me the Cushing Whitney
Cushing Whitney Medical Library has also
implemented a number of these as part of
their renovation which is actually I
believe opening on Thursday so if
anybody's interested in seeing them
there as well and here I just have an
image we can see a couple of them I'm
sorry I know this is probably not the
most clearest image but we can see that
we have a couple of the devices here at
som we have one right over here and we
have one right over here and with these
particular pieces of hardware you can
actually see that there's an LED strip
on either side of the device so even if
you don't walk right up to the device
from a distance you can actually see
whether or not a room is available and
decide if you want to go ahead and go to
that
and maybe have a meeting and so that's
gonna then bring us into survey
management and design so for that we use
Qualtrics to support this need and
Qualtrics can do so many things right
and we can see just some of those things
right here so we have student engagement
we have online course evaluations we
have dashboards we have patient care we
have employee experience and one of my
favorite things since this is sort of my
area here is that you can actually even
use it for really simple registration
and RSVP like that's pretty cool and so
it's available to all Yale faculty staff
and students for the business of the
university and in addition it is
approved for pH I data and Qualtrics
states that it is helpful in increasing
the speed and the quality of our
research and overall it improves our
engagement our experience and our user
satisfaction and I think that's pretty
much it for me so I think I'll go ahead
and turn this back over to Dan for him
to wrap us up and I thank you very much
yeah
[Applause]
I think I just get the final like thank
you slides so just wrapping this back to
our forward-looking statements all the
technologies that you saw we are trying
to actively knit those together into the
sails into a Salesforce CRM so that we
can start understanding the audience
insights that that we were talking about
earlier which is really really awesome
because then we can start to understand
it's like you know that one person that
comes into our community and how many
different places that they actually
touch and how many departments and and
you know and understand what their
interests actually are so that we can
better serve them and with that that's
it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]